but i do want to know this cat who would
you if you had to
you know move forward
uh between everyone in the room or just
my bosses
if you had to move forward by choice
okay some lucky
yes man in the room so any man in this
room not necessarily just my bosses
uh it's any man in this room okay and no
one is your boss right now
and no one has my body okay let me close
my eyes and just think we're all equal
and also each man gets one is going to
have 30 seconds to
at first plead their case as to why
they should be the one who gets to yeah
have you ever
let's go let's do it and it's for wife
it's not anything
sensual you can't breathe for a long
time
[Laughter]
nothing you guys are going to play back
later and masturbate
i can reach on my material man
and chin no insider trading either yeah
obviously on the great rules yeah okay
let's start off with uh let's start with
chappelle lacey
let me get a timer i'm going to pause 60
seconds well it's like that show
what was the show the blind date show
where they were oh yeah like behind the
wall
okay i'll close my eyes okay or maybe
catch could ask like three questions we
answer them okay
oh no just like the show like what would
you do on our first date and then
go through uh i don't know i do like
that we have to explain ourselves
i was kind of like prepping my monologue
in the time since you said it so
i would like to stick with the original
constraints get a monologue and then cat
gets to ask
one question maybe let's see how the
monologues go this could be a horrible
idea yeah let's play it by ear
okay we have 60 seconds nick you want to
run it yeah
uh run that [ __ ] uh should i join first
yeah
three two one go uh my name is chapelle
lacy
i'm 33 years old i'm an aquarius i'm a
great guy
i don't come with any extra baggage any
previous crazy relationship stuff
i like to read a lot i like to invest a
lot of time into
the relationships that i'm in to give my
best i like to deliver my
best to everyone around me 44
30 because you get weird
it's like at 30 doesn't leave him alone
30 more seconds
leave him alone
[Laughter]
all right all right nick appropriately
time's up
yes uh okay
that was a good joke thank you thank you
thank you yeah we slept online
can hear all of it then ask questions
okay oh then ask a question so about me
then yeah
all right mike's gonna size your voice a
little if you don't want cat to know who
it is
yeah you could do something like that
although we said the names already
okay somebody who somebody else can go
now
okay i'm not gonna say who i'm gonna
count down and just go since we decided
already
three two one go
as long as you teach your kid if we have
a kid as long as you teach him how to
google
he'll be the utmost perfect child that
knows how to do everything
100 than most other people
he's also he's he's also an anomaly in
height
uh so if he had a kid with this person
uh then he could be the tallest asian
ever
i don't want the voice is making it
worse
all right it's a beautiful singer that
it's already 30 seconds
obviously serial killer why that guy
needs alcohol
okay
he's the only date rapist that doesn't
date that doesn't look great
that's chin dude and that's a good thing
thank you and
that's a good thing but yeah i would
never i couldn't even imagine
it sounds like the lines got crossed and
somebody was just talking to somebody
oh okay
all right who's next a theo's next
mystery man number three someone is next
all right
three two one go
good afternoon um i would like to say my
name
is theo and that could be just a say
a fake name but um i am
for i'm from march i was born in march
and the one thing you get with me is a
decent guy
so you get a guy that wakes up every
morning goes to bed every night
you know you don't get like a crazy guy
that's
you know uh selling drugs or anything
like that or uh
you know having a bunch of baby mamas
are listening to a party
[Music]
that's pretty good that was pretty good
was that
am i up all right ready i'll go three
two one go
[Applause]
okay you ready you got it hey my name my
name is brendan
uh 37 years old
my friends would consider me thick
thicker
i ride my bike every day it's one of my
passions
i love animals i love animals one thing
about me i love to eat
i got sweet my friends would say i have
sweet teeth i'm a big foot
guy and uh i'm down for open
relationships
you're into black guys that's fine
okay last contestant here we go rides
bikes and then the black guys i mean
that guy sounds trouble he said you
sound homeless
yeah i ride my bike every day
to one go
um hi i'm nick um in
in in my dating history i've dated a
vietnamese girl so
know i know how to treat uh your kind i
guess
i i know i'm not the only one that dated
the vietnamese
girl in here but the other guy
was asian and i know asian girls don't
like other asians they usually go for
white guys
look chinese are the black people of the
asian community i used to live in my car
and i don't anymore
uh asian before and i don't think you
guys should be caged up
can i open my eyes yeah you guys ask a
question oh yeah
i do have a question for the last guy
okay uh i just wanted to know where did
you keep your girlfriend in a cage or a
kennel
on a pedestal
[Applause]
thanks jacko i have one question for the
first gentleman
uh who went he said that he's good in
bed at the very
end by bed do you mean taking naps and
are you a cuddler
yeah define bed yeah uh uh
touch is my love language so i am a
great cuddler
and uh yeah i do take naps about 20
minutes
every day every day a little power now
on the hour
oh yeah oh yeah oh wow
20 minutes every day on the hour but
that's a stereotype dude okay
yeah right you hear what he said about
me theo get him hurts my heart man yeah
come on i will fill out another con and
i will i do have seven
uh alternate accounts that i youtube
comment on
[Laughter]
and i will continue to use them with
human resources
which is just nick i'm black and most of
the complaints are against him
because i've dealt with your kind
for me okay
so going down the list i would say the
definite nose
is gonna be the what was it
the gentleman who said that he was also
asian
it kind of sounded like he was giving me
a description of
he is trying to like procreate not
necessarily be in a relationship like
out of duty and i'm looking for love
yeah i wasn't feeling him either i
noticed that else yeah
i feel the same way so that's chin and
he's out
next one is the gentleman who rides
bikes he says that he likes black men
and i don't know
i said it's okay if you can't rebuttal
brendan well don whoever
because she's confused i just say i like
oh okay that changes
okay that's fine you can rebuttal i'm
open to what i said
oh okay i thought you said you liked
black men i was going to tell you i
didn't like the show everyone's in the
hot tub drinking and
you know got it chappelle's in there
love language is touched let's put a
black guy in there though
okay
i love how open that gentleman is but i
feel like i can't deal with a cuck
i've kind of dealt with that in the past
can't do it now um
let's see and then there was a cup
dude r.i.p cuck dudes uh tried it did
not work
so let's see jesus uh
there's the guy who says that he is into
my kind he's dated my kind
and i'm gonna super racist let me oh it
wasn't no no no no no no no that was not
you
no i said you are kind oh you are kind
of shut the [ __ ] up
uh i'm gonna go ahead and say that's all
that's behind the glass
i'm going to go ahead and say that's a
hard no by referring to
my people as your kind it's going to be
a hard pass so it's going to be
20 nick yeah it's 20 20 brother stay
woke
there was a man who said that he is a
decent man who wakes up in the morning
and night
i liked that he was the most normal out
of everybody but it did sound like he
was going in for a job interview yeah
your ticker your ticker's off
yep that's fair um i think
out of all of them i would have to go
with the first contestant who's working
on themselves and touch is a love
language
wow that guy yeah guy you were a close
second i will say
look at you guys if you gave a little
more like
i'm looking for love i would have given
in i'll take a second because i don't
know if i was definitely down for it but
i wouldn't
make a choice for you but if something
happens to the first guy then i would
definitely i would step up and i would
be the man you need me to be
yeah like if the first day didn't go
well i'd hit you up like thank you
on the way home and that would be right
there second place is what you want now
you can be the bachelor
yeah yeah yeah you're that shoulder to
cry on yeah you know what i'm saying
well when i [ __ ] up that's a little too
much responsibility yeah
okay nevermind just kidding don't call
me all the time yeah no
no that was a fun game
is